[Music]
Christian
up
hello everybody how's everyone
doing good did anyone else wake up this
morning like me and just so confused
with the time change like I knew it was
going to happen and I was like ah I'm
getting up at 9:30 no it was 10:30 and I
was like what where am I what is
happening um as everyone trickles in
I'll go ahead and introduce myself my
name's miam for those that I have not
met um but I see a couple new faces so
nice to meet you all glad you all are
here I have a couple of announcements
for us before we get into worship so
next Sunday we are actually going to
have youth Sunday what that means is the
youth they're gonna do everything that
we do up here every Sunday so that it's
led by um the students and the adult
volunteers it's a way for them to we do
it a couple times a year if I'm not
mistaken but it's a way for them to kind
of share their love um of Christ and
their faith and kind of have the
opportunity to present and do things for
the church on that Sunday so definitely
attend if you're available um all these
next announcements go for Holy Week
leading up to Easter which I can't
believe it's already a couple weeks away
so uh make sure you mark these down if
you don't have them already so we're
going to have Palm Sunday on Sunday
March the 24th no change in time no
change in location um same time 5:00
just know that that Sunday will be Palm
Sunday Good Friday I had to ask Brett
how to say this word is going to be um
we're going to be joining the First saxi
Community for their Good Friday
Canada anyone know what that
is I didn't either I had to Google it
just what was it like head like music
music lots of music so it'll be a good
time um that will be 7 pm on Friday
March the 29th here in the sanctuary
March 29th 7 PM Easter Saturday not
Sunday we're gonna have it here at 5:00
pm. on uh March 30th remember there is a
potluck afterwards so if you want to
join it's a soup and bread and dessert
potluck so feel free to bring whatever
you'd like to do it'll be a good time
that'll follow immediately after service
on
Saturday last announcement regarding all
that is our our children's ministry
they're collecting um pre-filled Easter
eggs so if you want to drop those off
that would be greatly appreciated feel
free to bring them I would say you know
now until right before Easter anything
you bring can and will be used and you
can uh there will be um Team workers at
the check-in table you could leave it
with
them all right that's all I have for
announcement so I'm going to lead us in
a quick prayer uh before we go
into wanted to make sure my phone was on
silent so it didn't start ringing during
prayer so uh before we go into worship
um if y'all would like to Bow your heads
and pray with
me God first and foremost um I thank you
for getting everyone here safely and for
our friends and family that are here and
online I pray that you use Brett to
speak truth into all of us um if there's
anything that going through anything
that um we need reminders of um anything
of the sort I pray that you
are you have an overwhelming presence
Over Us in knowing that we are
loved and we are worthy just like we
always say at the end of every
service I pray that if anyone is going
through some hard times that again you
just lay your helping and Sovereign hand
over them you comfort
them and you remind them that they they
are loved and they are worthy of
everything that this life has to
offer I pray as we lead up to Easter
that we
remember continue to remember your word
and your sacrifices that you gave for us
I pray that we spend time with you that
we're able to just remember the greatest
gift that you gave to us which was
laying down your life so that we could
have ours
um
I pray all this in Jesus name
amen amen thank you Miriam um if you
guys want to stand with us kind of have
a a more even more acoustic set tonight
than we sometimes have um so you guys
feel free to clap fill out that space
with us we're going to start off with an
older song um and I'm just I I'm so
grateful tonight of the reminder that uh
there is a much bigger world than just
the one that I
experience and uh this week I had some
moments of just stress and feeling like
there wasn't enough of me to go around I
was letting people down it just felt
like too many plates spinning too many
needs not enough Mindy to solve it all
but you know there's the reminder that
that's not our like that's not what God
wants of us that's and he's not looking
at us disappointed um you know you know
counting all the things that were
getting wrong but instead inviting us
into his rest into his goodness into his
righteousness um and so anyways I hope
that tonight as you sing you're reminded
just of his bigness his ability um in
the midst of sometimes my inability but
he is good he is faithful and he's
enough so um God of Wonders is our first
song and that one always reminds me uh
he created a lot not just me so Carter
you want to get it
started if you know it sing it with
us Lord of all
creation of the water Earth and
Sky the heavens are your Tabernacle
glory to the Lord on
high God of Wonders beyond our
galaxy You Are
Holy
Holy the universe declares your
majesty You Are
Holy
Lord of Heaven and
Earth Heaven and Earth Lord of Heaven
[Music]
and early in the
morning I will C bre the
[Music]
light when I stumbled in the
darkness I will call your name by
night God of Wonders beyond our
galaxy You Are
Holy
Holy the universe declares your
majesty
You Are
Holy
holy Lord of Heaven and
Earth heav and Earth Lord of Heaven and
Earth
Hallelujah to the Lord of Heaven and
Earth Hallelujah to the Lord of Heaven
and Earth Hallelujah huah to the Lord of
Heaven and
Earth and All God's Children singing
Glory
Hallelujah He
reigns
heign All God's Children singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah He
reigns let's lift that up he All God's
Children Singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah he
Reign
he All God's Children singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah
he let's just lift our voices sing it
out all God Children singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah he
reign
All God's Children singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah last
time oh God's Children singing Glory
Glory
Hallelujah he
[Music]
re God wonders beyond our
galaxy you are
holy
holy the universe declares your
majesty You Are
Holy
Holy all right you kids are dismissed to
your
classrooms your teachers are going to
meet you over there at the doors and
then they will walk you back thank you
guys for joining
[Music]
us and thank you Casey Jennifer Britney
Maggie our teen helpers you guys are
awesome thanks so
much we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so if you guys
would read this prayer aloud with me and
then we will take some space for us to
speak out what you may be carrying on
your heart tonight and then we'll close
out the prayer together
Jesus for this city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and
light healing and hope peace and a deep
sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
God I look to
you I won't be over with
give me
wisdom to see things like you do God I
love to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisdom you know just what to
[Music]
do sing I will love you
Lord and I will Love You Lord my
strength and I will love you Lord my
Shi I will love you Lord my
rock forever all my days I will love you
[Music]
life
God I love to
you I won't be
overwhelmed give me
Vision to see things like you do God I
love to
you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisom you know just what to do and I
will love you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you Lord my
RO forever all my days I I will love you
God oh
[Music]
Hallelujah god
Ra oh
hallelujah our god
reigns Oh
hallelu Our God RS whoever all my days
hallelujah
I will love you and I will love you Lord
my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield and I will love you Lord my
rock forever all my days I will
[Music]
you I was listening to somebody on Tik
Tok a couple weeks ago by the name of
Lise Meyers some of you may recognize
the name she's just a really well-known
influencer and she really spoke
something into my heart that I feel like
has something to do with the next song
that we're singing which is canvas and
Clay some of you may know it um what she
talks about in the video is just to
picture this if you feel like you would
like to have the entire world just be
put on pause for a couple years so that
you feel like you can catch up with
everybody else to get to where you feel
like you think you should be in Life or
what you should have whether it be that
degree or that job or that house or that
spouse or that pet or whatever it may
be you know wanting those things she
just reminds she just I just want you to
know that you're doing a really great
job and I'm really proud of you and
you're exactly where you need to be and
you know comparison is the thief of Joy
so I just want yall to know that that
I'm proud of you for where you're at
today wherever you're at in life you're
exactly where you're supposed to be I
know that I needed to hear that and it
reminds me that we are kind of like that
canvas we are that that pot that God is
molding and when an artist makes a
painting sometimes those paintings can
take years and in the process he may be
thinking you know what is this going to
come out to be why am I not already at
the conclusion where I want to be but
it's all about that process and being
patient and then the next thing you know
you look back and there was a
masterpiece and your life is like that
your life is like that tapestry where
you look back and you say okay this
makes sense now this and this this is
why this happened this is why that
happens so anytime I question and wonder
like I need to be at this point in life
where I'm not successful or this I just
try to remember who's holding the
brush and the mind of the Divine entity
that is holding that brush has something
really special that we can look forward
to and we can remember that we are
simply the canvas and the clay and so
that's just a thought I want y'all to be
led into tonight as we start this song
so we can get
[Music]
started my mother's
in my mother's
womb you formed me with your hands known
and loved by
you before I took a breath when I doubt
it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist and a
part I'm the canvas and the clay
you make all
things work
together for my
[Music]
future and for my good you make all
things work
[Music]
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name there's a healing
light there's a healing
light just beyond the clouds though I've
walked through
fire I see clearly now I know nothing
has been wasted no failure or mistake
you're an artist and a poter I'm the
canvas and the
CL and you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together For Your
[Applause]
Glory and for your name and you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your glory
and for your
[Music]
name oh I doubt it when I doubt it Lord
remind me I'm wonderfully made you're an
arst and aart
I'm the canvas and the clay and I know
nothing has been wasted no failure
mistake your vanst stand upon it I'm the
C the clay when I doubt it Lord remind
me I'm
wonderful you're an artist and a part
I'm the
in the CL I know nothing has been wasted
no
failure St you're in arest in the part
I'm the CH in the clay and you make all
things work
together for my
fure and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name you're not
finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me yet you're
not finished with me you're not finished
with me yet you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
me you're not finished with
[Music]
me God would you remind us that you're
doing a good
work and you will do it to
completion you will bring about the
growth you will bring about the healing
and the
[Music]
Redemption God would we open oursel up
to it would we lean into it would we
pursue
it would we go after it because it's
always available to us your goodness
your
love your
forgiveness it's always
here help us to engage it
God make us new from the inside
out and give us
patience as you continue your
Masterpiece as you do your
work let us let us trust the process let
us trust the
artist let us be
moldable thank you for your love thank
you for who you are that you're a good
God it's in your name we pray
amen would you guys welcome the people
around you help them to feel at home and
then Brett will get us started on our
message
you're good you good you
good oh Grace and
peace it is it's good to be with you all
so so glad um well welcome to the table
my name is Brett and um it's a joy just
a joy to be with you and that as always
it includes everyone it ALS Al includes
those join us online love yall lots and
um anyone here tonight Who's new uh
thank you for just being being Among Us
I know it can take a lot of courage to
come through those doors so uh it was it
was everyone's first time at some point
and we know what that's like so yeah so
thank you for being here um so we are in
um see this is week three in our series
um titled lint with Julian of
Norwich and uh for those unfamiliar
amiliar so lint is the the season of
kind of preparation healing repentance
as we approach uh Good Friday so it's
like the day of the Cross when we'll be
uh here joining with uh Saxy first and
their
Canada which would be cool um and uh so
that's good Friday and then Easter which
again for us is Saturday um so it's kind
of that it's yeah it's that kind of time
of preparation which if you grew up like
I did in kind of Evangelical tradition
is a little bit different because
usually we just kind of celebrate Easter
you know and we don't necessarily do
this whole like kind of reflection and
all that but I found a lot of value in
it we try he the table not to have it be
like overly heavy you know um kind of
like w like your sins five weeks on your
sins you know um although granted if
you're in our Series so with so let me
kind of frame this up so Julian norit
she was a Christian Mystic uh who lived
from 1343 to around 1416 or so and uh
she wrote this book Revelations of
divine love kind of capturing these
visions that she she felt like she had
and in chapter 51 of that book uh she
recounts this Vision Vision where she
saw a um a servant who she said is like
representative of humanity and then um
who she calls like the Lord um
represented of God and this kind of Lord
or kingly figure gives the the servant
this um like task or Mission and the
servant she said uh like just runs off
to do the Lord's will and almost
immediately Falls deep into this pit and
there experiences what she names the
seven Great Pains of sin which again
that can sound very Linton you know it's
like the great Pains of sin I me you can
hear in that language like kind of the
medieval Christianity you know it's
pretty intense but uh I've said every
week that uh Julian she's everyone's um
favorite Mystic uh because she has this
just such a beautiful image of God and
and her like such compassion overflowing
so which we'll get more to that in a
moment so the title of my message this
week is the pit uh Julian wrote these
words she said the place where he lay it
was deep it was
constricted and very
hard so a few weeks ago we talked talked
about the effects of the pit on us as we
we talked about the word bruised um that
are like shortcomings and things can
leave us feeling like almost tender uh
and then last week we were talking about
um the aloneness of the pit the the
strange way that in our moments of
deepest need like when we most need to
connect with others what do we
do we like distance we run away you know
this is kind of the danger of of the pit
uh so those were kind of Reflections on
on like the effects of the pit on us
this week I want to take some time to
just think through the pit
itself uh and and what that experience
is like and what's kind of going on
there um now I say that Julian's
everyone's favorite Mystic because that
Compassionate Heart now the way she
frames the pit is as just a total
accident she's like I saw the servant it
just ran off and he just accidentally
fell into this pit you know which can
happen you know sometimes we just like
make a mistake or mess up or something
it's like to be human you know we we
mess up uh
so many of my messages have kind of been
conducive to that image this week is not
like this week when I'm thinking of this
this pit you know uh I'm not thinking of
kind of what Julian's thinking of like
you know the accidents um I'm not even
thinking of just you know suffering in
general like just you know bad things
happen in a fallen world and we often
interpret it as like God's judging me
he's getting back at me for whatever
that thing I did in high school or I
don't know whatever uh and I just
someone to say that like no no no no um
instead today what I'm kind of thinking
of is is these moments maybe I'm alone
in this I suspect not where I've got my
shovel
out and I am actively like digging the
very pit that I'm falling into and then
I fall in and I'm like hey can someone
give me that shovel thank you and I just
keep digging my my wife Maggie is like
Brett uh you sure you want to dig that
pit I'm like
absolutely and my kids are like Dad you
sure I'm like yep and all my friends
like we don't know man we don't know
it's just this seems unwise and I'm like
don't tell me how to live my life like
I'm gonna I'm going to do this this is
this is happening have you ever been
there in that kind of pit where it's
like everyone around you can see
it but for whatever reason you can't
or you can and you kind of know but like
your ego is not allowing you to admit
that like okay this is a disaster you
know uh and it just keep going and so
that's that's like that's the the pit I
have in mind tonight like and of course
it's different for everyone you know uh
I mean it's 10,000 different things and
even in ways what is a pit for one
person is not for another you know
because it's often how we engage a thing
that is like determines its sort of
healthfulness and goodness for us or a
disaster shambles you know it's it it
varies I'm I'm thinking of those um I
mean probably to put it sort of uh
simply be like those life lessons you
know but I'm thinking of like like
anything
maybe like there's always right the
generations um that come before us and
I'm thinking of like all those things
that that previous generations look
at say me and they're like
Brett don't do it like no I've been down
that path don't go there I've been in
that pit don't like that it is not the
answer to your self-esteem needs like
it's not the answer you think it will be
you know I mean like we all know these
things where the old generation's like
no and we can see it often for the
younger generation we're just like no
you know to all the middle schoolers now
I'm I'm raising a a I've been through
now middle school with my kids and um
one of them is now a high schooler so I
can just see these things you know where
it's just like no don't do it and it's
like it's those types of things where
we're like I hear you I hear
you but no like I'm gonna do it anyway
this is often how I think people like
this has been my experience of mentoring
and being mentored like have you ever
had this season where you're just like I
just need a mentor I just need someone
to like show me the ropes to tell me you
know to guide me around these pits and
such and then you like get a
mentor and then what do we do we just
freaking ignore the mentor you know what
I mean they're like you know I would
probably do it this way and you're like
yeah thank you thank you so much for the
input I really appreciate that no you
know what I mean like you just do like I
really found this like people just
pretty much we are just going to do what
we want to do aren't we I mean if we're
just being honest like we just kind of
do it
and um the way I would kind of maybe sum
this up is there's something in human
beings that longs to learn a thing for
ourselves even if the
lesson is painful and costly and
slightly terrible it's like we ju we
just need I just need to know it for
myself and that's where I'm not even you
know really my purpose in this message
isn't to like shame you know where to
say like yeah why don't we listen you
don't listen to your mentors than you
should or you know like no actually I'm
saying like I get it I get it I'm there
with you like we really I really do
again this is I take this as a truth
like I really do think we actually need
to learn things for
ourselves and sometimes that
pit it's like the best teacher in the
world it teaches us things like no
Mentor no pastor no Bible verse I mean
put it in Catholic terms the Virgin Mary
could show up in your prayer time and
just be like don't do this go there you
know I mean you're just like N I just
don't trust it you know like it just we
just gota we got to learn thing and I
must say this is where um I just kind of
Marvel at the uh the patience and the
goodness of
God
who man the Lord like she would just
just wa wait me
out just Waits just
patiently
patiently just waiting for for
me to
figure it out whether that's a week or a
year or a decade or decades I mean I
don't know about you I have like a
hundred pits going at once you know at
varying levels they're not all super
intense and you know um and and that's
okay again this the point isn't to shame
to be like how dare you have that pit
you're a Christian you should have no
like no you're a human being like yes
we're Christians we're human beings and
we're TR we're trying to figure it out
and and it's there's there's just just a
powerful um process in this but this is
where I just I do I love the Lord who
just like she just waits for us um to
come home I mentioned um Luke 15 a few
months ago in a sermon usually I try to
like spread the passages out but I'm
just coming back to this story it's a
Jesus parable classic and I just adore
it the the story of the prodal son um so
it says this Luke 15: 11 Jesus continued
there was a man who had two sons the
younger one said to his father father
give me my share of the estate so he
divided his property between them I just
I want you to kind of think of this
whole story for many of you this will be
familiar um perhaps not everyone um and
I want you to think of it in the context
of the pit right so notice
the father's reaction here I mean what
does it say just like so he divided his
property between them just like that I
mean no like wait what you're you want
to do what like oh that's unwise you
shouldn't do you know like you just and
and of course if you know the rest of
the story this is like a whole Parable
the the father is um symbolic of of God
and like this is how we go like just
notice the the father's just like okay
you know like sure you want to journey
into the far country which as we'll see
in a minute that's where he goes uh so
in other words no
arguing no
shaming no
manipulating like none of that it's just
like
okay H this
is this is something I'm learning myself
as a parent right now I've uh like I
mentioned my kids are starting to get at
least a little older what 14 um 14 12 10
or 11 I get my kids agees
confused oh nine oh that's the threeyear
Gap is there 14 12 and nine thank you
Mindy in-law Mindy in-law sister-in-law
Mindy that
um so so they're getting right they're
just getting that stage older and uh
like in the younger years you have so
much control you know what I mean of
like do this don't do that or at least
you feel you you feel you do I've
learned you don't have as much as you
think but at least you have the illusion
of it you know but as they get older
like it's just it's just different you
know and you can discipline and teach
and control and argue and like all the
things but at the end of the day they're
going to live their life like it's just
it's not your life this is I I really I
think I did I had this crazy illusion
where if I'm the perfect parent then
they're going to be the perfect kids you
know it's like of course like I had good
parents I'm not perfect you know like is
not how it works and there is it's like
as a parent you're you're being
invited into this um just profound
surrender it's just this this kind of
letting go and of course what's true in
the par parental relationship like
that's true with even just friends I
don't know if you got you don't have to
raise your hand for this one but any
kind of high control people who like you
can see people who you really value you
know in your life and they're going a
road that you don't feel good about and
there's what happens it's like your own
anxiety kind of gets the best of you and
you want to
like no no no you know like it's this
this whole thing of trying to get them
to either sort of um prevent them from
falling into the pit or kind of
codependent trying to like get them out
you know when the truth is man if
they're in it like they might want to be
there you know what I mean like they're
this is the season they're in and
they've again they've we've got to um
maybe one way to think of it is
like giving people the Dignity of their
Journey where you say like you have
agency you it's your life it's not my
life um by the way pastors are notorious
for this being a huge
problem you know and I I have to work at
that you know to just like you're on
your own Journey it's not it's yours you
know and and there is I think that can
there's a a freedom that we need to even
give to one another to say you know what
it's not it's not my life you know this
you are for you and and I need the
Dignity of my journey and you need um
the Dignity of
yours continuing on verse 13 not long
after that the younger son got together
all he had he set off for a distant
country and there squandered his wealth
in Wild living after he had spent
everything there was a severe famine in
that whole country and he began to be in
need so he went and hired himself out to
a citizen of that country who sent him
to his fields to feed pigs he longed to
fill his stomach with the pods that the
pigs were eating but no one gave him
anything
uh notice here that what's what's
happening like the pit is doing all of
the teaching isn't it like I mean
where's the father at this point like
notice that the father like didn't like
secretly go to the far country and start
like sabotaging his son's life or like
no no no it's none of that it's just the
the pit like life just does all of the
teaching
there's a a part in this very silly
movie The Little Rascals I'm thinking of
the 9s version though I think that's
like has anyone seen this a few of you I
adore this movie I'm like vicariously
you know reliving movies now with
through the kids you know so they so
they adore this which I'm so happy so
it's like I don't watch it much anymore
now it's just playing in the back of my
van so I've heard the audio of this a
lot recently and uh but there's this
like hilarious scene where so if you
don't know like little Ras right there
uh it's this weird boys club and they're
they're learning the whole story is them
basically learning not to be so sexist I
guess is like they kind of they're on
this journey and but there's a point
where their Clubhouse like burns down so
they need uh they need to buy new ones
they're trying to fundraise for it and
so they decide to go to the bank you
remember the scene that like one's
sitting on the other shoulder so they
try to look like adults and they have
like a long like a insanely long trench
coat I me they must be like 7et tall it
looks ridiculous fake beard s you know
the whole like it's so silly and of
course they need for the movie The the
adults in the bank can't tell that it's
you know at least the beginning um and
so they come in there and you know the
banker um super rude to them they're
like my good man we need a we need a
loan you know and and he's like what's
your uh what's your bank what's your
account number then what did does anyone
remember what they say it's is it 71
it's something like that like it's just
a one-digit like seven seven that's what
it yeah seven that's your you know so
finally the Banker's like he's all
hacked off he's like what you're just
kids and he snaps the beard you know
he's like you you get out of here he
said of if I if you were my kids I'd
punish you and then The Little Rascals
you remember what they say if we were
your kids we'd punish
ourselves and I love that line because
I'm thinking like in a way that's like
the whole message is the pit like again
we interpret it as God oh God's got me
in this pit God's doing this and God's
doing that God just hates me no no like
sin is its own punishment we we are
doing almost everything to ourselves you
know it's this it's this um feedback
loop of Life coming back on us uh Father
Richard Roar and I would say this is one
of his more provocative quotes I don't
even know if I agree with it I mean it's
really out there but i' still like it I
I think of this quote all the time he he
put it this way he said I do not think
you should get rid of your sin until you
have learned what it has to teach
you a that that's I mean that's kind of
I'm thinking at a very literal level
like where you know could I actually
suggest that like I don't know like
maybe just get rid of it you know um but
I get exactly what he's saying you know
like in
essence um in essence maybe some of the
reason we're even struggling to get rid
of or to let go or whatever ever is like
cuz we still we just haven't learned it
yet you know like
will yeah what are the things life and
shortcoming struggles what is what is
this trying to say what's getting said
to us in these things like that I think
it's such a it's almost a more Curious
way to engage with some of our
shortcomings instead of this kind of
very combative you know I do that is
what I ad door about um about that quote
that the pit is just such a powerful
teacher in our lives uh verse
17 when he came to his senses he said oh
how many of my father's hired servants
have food to spare and here I am
starving to death I'll set out I'll go
back to my father and I'll say to him I
love his little speech here father I've
sinned against heaven and against you
I'm no longer worthy to be called your
son make me like one of your hired
servants so he got up and he went to his
father but while he was was still a long
way off his father saw him was filled
with compassion for
him and he ran to his son and he threw
his arms around him and he kissed
him what a stunning image of
God like that's like that's who God
is I love Julian has a quote that just
ties in beautifully with this she said I
came to
how God views our own tendency to miss
the Mark I realized that it is our own
pain that blames and punishes us our
gracious Lord offers nothing but comfort
and sucker he's always kindly inclined
toward us loving us unconditionally and
wanting only to bring us joy you see why
Julian's everyone's favorite Mystic
you see this is the father heart the
mother Heart Of God for us so it just
doesn't it doesn't
matter how deep in the pit you feel you
are how like far you feel you've
journeyed into the far
country the moment you're ready the
moment you get
it and you cry out and you're like oh my
gosh I need to be saved you know in that
big sense not just in some you know walk
the aisle but like in the big sense um
like the Lord is there just like this
father with no no shame no blame no
condemnation no judgment no you know
fury like no just just the love of God
is there to meet
you so for everyone tonight who may feel
just a little too far
gone too deep in the pit the word of the
Lord to you is no no you are seen you
are loved and rescue is close at
hand in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine we eat we drink
rescue rescue we we we take in The God
Who is with us present to us even there
in the pit for as long as we need to be
there yeah the one who sees us and loves
us so I hope as you come forward that
can be the the kind of heart posture um
that you engage uh this time of uh of
communion with so um the way that we'll
do this is we're um just going to start
here kind of at the front row and we'll
just work our way back so when one row
finishes the next one can go ahead and
and get up we'll just form one line
right through here and uh there'll be
two people serving the cup that way you
can kind of Branch off and go in the
direction that you need to um we've
practiced what's called an open table so
if you're here tonight and something in
you would like to participate then um
you're welcome to you know regardless of
your exact like theology or
denominational affiliation or whatever
uh if if something in you wants to
connect with the Risen Christ then um we
we would love for you to do that having
said that there's no Stigma if you're
not in a place where you want to do that
that's perfectly fine uh too um you
should also know the red is wine the
white is grape juice so uh so this is
the table not of the
church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith in
you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to theable
table
e
for
we're going to sing the words of that
bridge one more time when I doubt it
Lord remind me I'm fearfully and
wonderfully made you're the
artist I'm the
clay you guys are welcome to just stay
seated and sing that with us or if you'd
like to stand and sing it with your
hands open whatever feels like the
posture um of where you're at just enter
in that way but let's close out just
remembering that he is good like Brett
said he is waiting with his arms open to
receive us with love compassion and
kindness
[Music]
when I doubted Lord
remind I'm wonderfully made you're an
arest and
a I'm the canvas and the clay and I know
nothing has been Wast it no failure or
mistake you're an arst stand
a I'm the and the CL when I doubt Lord
REM I'm wonderfully made you're an
artist and
a I'm the canvas and
Clay
hased failure mistake you're an arst
stand aart
the the clay and you make
all
together for my
future and for
my you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your your name you're not
finished with
me you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me
[Music]
um I just want to thank everyone for
joining us tonight whether you're here
in person or online um especially to our
our new friends that are here if you are
new uh I would encourage you to either
scan that code that's up behind me the
QR code or fill out a little slip on
this table to your right that way we can
just follow up with you and see if we
can be there for you in any way and then
thank you for joining us as
well if you are in need of any prayer
hug I5 encouragement feel free to come
find me after the service I'd be happy
to be there for you in any way that I
can here at the table we are committed
to creating an inclusive Christ centered
environment and community in order for
us to do so that does require um some
help from our members as well so if you
feel led to give again you can scan that
QR code or fill out a slip on the table
to your right um before you head out
today I'm going to go ahead and send us
out with a blessing or a benediction you
can um receive this in any way that you
feel comfortable whether that's eyes
closed hands out um whatever feels
comfortable for
you you are a child of
God you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and this
is especially true on your worst day so
as you go into your week ahead with it's
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just the way that you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts to everyone that you come in
contact with be blessed and we'll see
you next
[Music]
week Lord remind me I'm wonderfully made
you're an artist and
a I'm the and the CL I know nothing has
been
wasted no failure
mistake an arst stand apart I'm the and
the
[Music]
CL you're not fin with me we trust you
with me
you're not finished with
me not finished with
me you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with
me you're not finished with with
me